[Music]  you can't control everything Katy Perry  suffers a major wardrobe malfunction and  flashes the American Idol audience  the pop star shared a clip on Twitter  Monday's seemingly making light of  splitting her pants on national TV while  rocking a silver sequin jumpsuit Katy  brought attention to her wardrobe limp  by doing this  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  Oh fellow judge Lionel Richie did his  best to shield Perry from the crowd  thankfully it was all resolved quickly  with some tape well this isn't the first  time Perry has flashed a little more  than expected on the show  I don't need to overexpose myself during  an idol audition the singer was dancing  with a Venezuelan contestant and fell  while wearing a mini dress there are  things a man can't unsee  American Idol airs Sunday and Monday  nights on ABC that was the part of the  show you will turn in for okay  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]